Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Do you remember the amazing pix2pix algorithm
from last year?
It was able to perform image translation,
which means that it could take a daytime image
and translate it into a nighttime image, create
maps from satellite images, or create photorealistic
shoes from a crude drawing.
I remember that I almost fell off the chair
when I've first seen the results.
But this new algorithm takes it up a notch,
and transforms these edge maps into human
faces, not only that, but it also animates
them in time.
As you see here, it also takes into consideration
the fact that the same edges may result in
many different faces, and therefore it is
also willing to gives us more of these options.
If I fell out of the chair for the still image
version, I don't really know what the appropriate
reaction would be to this.
It can also take a crude map of labels, where
each color corresponds to one object class,
such as roads, cars or buildings, and it follows
how our labels evolve in time and creates
an animation out of it.
We can also change the meaning of our labels
easily, for instance, in the lower left, you
see how the buildings are now suddenly transformed
to trees.
Or, we can also change the trees to become
buildings.
Do you remember motion transfer from a couple
videos ago?
It can do a similar variant of that too, and
even synthesizes the shadows around the character
in a reasonably correct manner.
As you see, the temporal coherence of this
technique is second to none, which means that
it remembers what it did with past images
and doesn't do anything drastically different
for the next frame, and therefore generates
smoother videos.
This is very apparent, especially when juxtaposed
with the previous pix2pix method.
So, how is this achieved?
There are three key differences from the previous
technique to achieve this:
One, the original architecture uses a generator
neural network to create images, where there
is also a separate discriminator network that
judges its work and teaches it to do better.
Instead, this work uses two discriminator
neural networks, one checks whether the images
look good one by one, and one more discriminator
for overlooking whether the sequence of these
images would pass as a video.
This discriminator cracks down on the generator
network if it creates sequences that are not
temporally coherent and this is why we have
minimal flickering in the output videos.
Fantastic idea.
Two, to ease the training process, it also
does it progressively, which means that the
network is first faced with an easier version
of the problem that progressively gets harder
over time.
If you have a look at the paper, you will
see that the training is both progressive
in terms of space and time.
I love this idea too.
Three, it also uses a flow map that describes
the changes that took place since the previous
frame.
Note that this pix2pix algorithm was published
in 2017, a little more than a year ago.
I think that is a good taste of the pace of
progress in machine learning research.
Up to 2k resolution, 30 seconds of video,
and the source code is available.
Congratulations folks, this paper is something
else.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!